Hollywood lined up plenty of successful
horror projects in 2017 from Jordan
peels breakthrough hit get out to the
revival of Stephen King's it to the
Groundhog's Day Redux happy deathday
looking ahead to 2018 there are already
quite a few flicks poised to satisfy
fright bands from fact-based stories to
supernatural scares and the re-emergence
of at least one classic character the
future looks very dark indeed in the
best possible way insidious the last key
demonologist Elise Ranier has been a
staple of the insidious series despite
meeting her end in the first entry after
appearing is only a spirit in the second
film the character was given the full
prequel treatment with insidious chapter
3 which focused on one of the case files
from her early days and explored how she
came to meet partners specs and Tucker
now insidious the last key is expected
to return to Elise's story picking up
where chapter 3 left off only this time
she's investigating a haunting of her
own family home from the looks at the
film's trailer it's going to be just as
chock-full of jump-scares as the rest of
the series when it hits theaters January
5th Day of the Dead bloodline
reimagining George Romero is quite a
tricky proposition especially when we're
talking about 1985 s Day of the Dead
which is one of the more controversial
entries in the Night of the Living Dead
series for it's unprecedented level of
violence and gore Spanish writer
director Hector Hernandez vez ends will
attempt to make it work though with a
loose adaptation titled Day of the Dead
bloodline
this ends made a few waves in 2015 with
this controversial but well received the
corpse of Anna Fritz but the bodies
should be a little livelier this time
around the new day will drop on January
5th with a simultaneous theatrical and
digital HD release strangers prey at
night
The Strangers was a surprise hit in 2008
thanks to its slow burn brutality and
subversion of certain flawed
expectations
- I missed us
gives you a home and even though the
first sequel was announced shortly after
the film's release it's taken the better
part of a decade to make it happen the
new film takes place at a trailer park
in the middle of nowhere during a power
outage and features christina hendricks
as the head of a family whose road trip
takes an unfortunate turn count on this
one to creep everyone out when it lands
in theaters March 9th the New Mutants
writer director Josh Boone is probably
best known for his adaptation of the
romantic drama novel The Fault in Our
Stars but not for long a longtime fan of
the Marvel comic book series the New
Mutants
boo and apparently blew away Fox
executives with his pitch for a film
adaptation of the property a straight-up
horror movie based on a particularly
dark run by legendary writer Chris
Claremont and artist Bilson cabbage
unlike other Marvel mutant films the New
Mutants is much less sci-fi centric and
much more focused on the fright factors
of its characters and with a cast that
includes split in the which alum anya
taylor joy alongside game of thrones
Maisie Williams and stranger things star
Charlie Eaton the new mutants should be
the one to watch when it hits theaters
on April 13 Slender Man based on one of
the most notorious internet memes of all
time Slender Man is expected to give
cinematic life to the viral villain that
has stuck the web since 2009 the
character was first born when a
Photoshop contest produced a picture of
the tall thin faceless stalker of
hapless children the forum poster who
made the image Erik Newton even has a
writing credit on the film under his
forum handle Victor surged a development
he probably didn't expect when he set
out to freak out a few people with his
photoshop skills Sony scream gems has
slated Slender Man for release on May
18th the purge the island the ending of
2016 s the purge election year seemed to
shut the door pretty firmly on the idea
of more sequels but the series has
garnered such a huge fanbase that the
purge the island is now expected to
explore the beginnings of the tidal
slaughterfest creator james demonaco
told vulture that had set in Staten
Island New York where the first
experimental purge took place and
it'll begin with people being paid to
participate which incentivizes very poor
people to try their luck at surviving
the night of mayhem and violence as the
monaco said so you see the inception of
how grotesque the idea of the purge is
and the manipulation upon the society
the purge the island is set to hit
theaters on July 4th the nun the series
that newline is now officially calling
the conjuring universe scored another
box-office hit with Annabelle creation a
pre prequel exploring the origins of the
sinister doll from the conjuring pushing
the series worldwide box-office take up
over the 1 billion dollar mark hitting
those kinds of numbers can only ensure
plenty more films in the pipeline and
first up is another spin-off than none
which will add some backstory to one of
conjuring twos most terrifying
characters the story will Center on the
characters backstory as a romanian nun
who ended her own life and the film will
start AE safar Myka in the lead with
Bonnie Aaron's reprising her role as the
demonic nun the lack the nun will return
to scare your pants off on July 13th a
house with a clock in its walls it
sounds like a rather Harry Potter s
premise a ten-year-old boy moves in with
an eccentric uncle only to find his
house is full of secret passageways and
strange and creepy goings on it's
eventually revealed that his uncle is a
warlock a witch lives next door and the
house has a conduit for weird black
magic rituals but JK Rowling won't be
calling her lawyers anytime soon this is
the plot of the 1973 gothic horror novel
the house with a clock in its walls and
an adaptation is forthcoming with some
serious talent on board notorious gore
master Eli Roth will direct a cast that
includes Kyle MacLachlan along with Cate
Blanchett Jack Black and Rene Elise
Goldsberry
this has an out of left field horror
smash written all over it
as long as Roth can keep his more
exploitative tendency to check look for
this film to hit theaters on September
21st
something in the dark this tech based
thriller has a unique premise a blind
woman has her sight restored by a pair
of high-tech I glasses but unfortunately
her vision may now be a little better
than she bargained for as she can now
see ghosts further complicating matters
they look just like normal people which
means she can't tell the difference
between the dead and the living even
worse she begins to suspect that a
lurking entity she keeps seeing might be
coming for her the film is expected to
be dialogue free but if the super creepy
trailer is any indication something in
the dark could be a breakout horror hit
when it's released on October 15
Halloween the Halloween reboot series by
Rob Zombie was so-so at best but with
funny man Danny McBride the producers
David Gordon Green coming together to
work on the concept for the new film the
new version of the holiday favorite
might just work the duo pitched directly
to original director co-writer John
Carpenter and carpenters reaction was
enough to get any fans heart racing he
wrote on Facebook David and Danny both
came to my office recently with Jason
Blum and shared their vision for the new
movie and Wow
they get it I think you're gonna dig it
McBride has since explained his vision
like so the first Halloween just works
on such a gut level of you know there's
someone who's escaped an asylum and he's
in this town you know that was what we
were wanting to do with this rather than
being a reboot it's expected to be more
of a sequel to the original film
Miramax will release the film on October
19th just in time for the scariest night
of the year
Nosferatu the witch is widely considered
to be among the scariest films of 2015 a
unique and ambitious picture that was
the directorial debut of production
designer turned director Robert Decker's
the film grossed 10 times its budget and
for his follow-up Eggers isn't scaling
back on his ambition he'll be helming
the remake of the seminal 1922 horror
classic Nosferatu and undertaking only
attempted once before in 1979 by
acclaimed German filmmaker Werner Herzog
a Gers gift for atmosphere should serve
him well on this project which even
mrs. Dante briefly tempted to table to
remake he told Collider that he
reconsidered it feels ugly and
blasphemous and egomaniacal and
disgusting for a filmmaker in my place
to do Nosferatu next I was really
planning on waiting a while but that's
how fate shook out it's safe to say the
remake is in very good hands and if the
witch is any indication fans might be in
for the creepiest vampire flick in years
deep blue sea to the 1999 cult classic
deep blue sea is a film that has
everything there's giant mutant sharks a
Bible quoting LL Cool J in his parrot
sidekick and a thundering samuel
l.jackson monologue that ends in the
most alaria sand inevitable way possible
we're going together it's one of the
most fun popcorn movies of the 90s and
it even turned a decent profit but plans
for a sequel have repeatedly fallen
through until now the sci-fi channel
purveyors of the finest shark bass
schlock of this or any age reportedly
took on shooting the long awaited deep
blue sea - it may not be getting a
theatrical release but sci-fi seems like
a good home for the project which will
hopefully live up to the fantastically
cheesy legacy of its predecessor puppet
master the littlest rush puppet master
didn't seem destined to crank out sequel
after sequel when it made its
direct-to-video debut in 1989 but the
franchise has proved to have remarkable
staying power focused on evil puppets
animated by an ancient curse and the man
who created them the film has already
spawned no fewer than 10 sequels this
year's puppet master access termination
the first installment since 2012 they
viewed in September on Amazon but the
team behind next years the littlest
Irish have assembled enough talent that
fans are crossing their fingers hoping
for a theatrical release the film will
star stone-faced veteran actor utopia as
the deranged puppet master Toulon and
genre Queen Barbara Crampton will also
make an appearance most of the action is
expected to take place at a convention
where killer puppets will run
and producers have promised a bloody
good time with plenty of practical Gore
effects when the film arrives sometime
next year
piranha jpn teeth of the Piranha 1978's
piranha has the distinction of being
hands down the best jaws ripoff in a sea
of ripoffs and it also launched the
career of director Joe Dante in much the
same way that it's less loved sequel
gave a boost to future Hollywood Titan
James Cameron the modern reboot series
which began with 2010's Verano 3d has
nobly carried on the tradition of
delivering maximum cheese along with
copious amounts of gore and bare bodies
so we're pleased to report that the next
installment titled piranha jpn teeth of
the piranha is expected to drop sometime
next year
Polaroid although unrelated issues with
the Weinstein Company and Dimension
Films have caused delays in the release
of Polaroid a supernatural thriller
originally slated for a Thanksgiving
2017 release the film still looks
bonkers enough to survive the executive
changes under way of the studio
first-time feature director Lars clef
Berg adapts from his own short film
telling the story of a teenage loner who
discovers an old Polaroid camera in a
mysterious store the budding photo
enthusiast soon finds that anybody she
takes a picture of is in line for a
horrific death at the hands of some
malevolent force while the premise might
seem a touch familiar or specifically
like a mash up of the ring and final
destination cleft Berg's film won Best
Short and Best Cinematography Awards at
the prestigious Los Angeles horror
competition and all signs in the trailer
point to a stylish lay shot and creepy
flick thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our youtube
channel let's check out all this cool
stuff we know you love to